[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous le mettez les gens en mouvement
quand leur proposant une histoire dans
laquelle ils reconnaissent leur monde
pour moi cette citation a été un peu
révélatrices et je me suis demandé
pendant longtemps
qu'est ce qui finalement freiner
l'engagement et pourquoi la notion
d'engagement pouvait paraître très
dogmatique pour certains et même
abstraite pour d'autres personnes
la première chose pour moi vient de la
sacralisation
on a sacralisé les figures de
l'engagement entre l'abbé pierre nelson
mandela en passant par martin luther
king et simone veil -le ses figures
emblématiques semble avoir été touchée
d'une grâce divine et ils semblent être
des modèles de vertu et de témérité
c'est un peu compliqué de s'y retrouver
dans tout ça et d'un autre côté la
machine mondiale
la machine économique qui semble
tellement complexe que l'engagement
semble impossible pour nous c'est
notamment une notion qui a été développé
par günther anders dans le cas du
décalage prométhéen et qu'est ce que
c'est ça c'est le décalage entre ce que
nous faisons et ce que nous pensons
entre notre faculté production et notre
faculté de sentir de penser et ça c'est
vraiment pour moi quelque chose qui
incarne la société actuelle la machine
est devenu tellement complexe que
finalement malgré qu'on puisse prenez
des discours humaniste et des valeurs
très fortes dans notre quotidien on a
tendance à peu les mettre en valeur
mais en même temps c'est normal
finalement l'enjeu a l'air tellement un
dimensionnable que on se sent vraiment
impuissant est vraiment très faible
vis-à-vis de cette machine géante
alors j'ai développé un concept parce
que pour moi tout ça c'est faux
finalement qui s'appelle le triple
malentendus et qu'est ce que c'est pour
moi le triple malentendu c'est
considérer qu'être une figure engagée
nécessite forcément un d'être un expert
de d'être un modèle de vertu et 3 d'être
un leader né il ya cinq ans j'ai engagé
ma propre révolution dans un secteur que
nous connaissons tous et qui nous fait
tous très peur
la finance et quand j'ai commencé à
travailler en finance
pour moi c'était impossible de
révolutionner ses modèles ça avait l'air
tellement en places gérées par des
forces des lobbyings tellement suprême
mais j'ai pas pu m'empêcher parce que
j'ai passé mon bac en 2008 je suis une
enfant de la crise financière et pour
moi si je voulais vraiment avoir un
impact au niveau économique
je devais travailler sur la colonne
vertébrale de l'économie qui était pour
moi la finance et donc je me suis
associé avec julien mon partenaire de
travail et avec julien on s'est posé une
question comment faire pour simplifier
cette finance la transformer et la met
au profit d'une économie qui partagent
nos valeurs
et quand j'ai démarré il ya quatre ans
avec julien 1
on n'était vraiment pas des experts de
l'est n'était pas non plus un modèle de
vertu croyez moi et 3 je reconnais ce
pont est pas vraiment à l'archétype du
leader charismatique et pourtant je vais
vous expliquer comment j'ai fait pour
combattre ces trois stéréotypes et
pourquoi au final ce sont ces
stéréotypes qui nous mèneront vers un
vrai effondrement le premier stéréotypes
pour réussir une révolution sectoriel il
faut être un expert en france on est les
principaux garants de la technocratie
donc quand il a démarré avec julien dans
un secteur financier ultra complexe
comment vous dire que les pontes de
notre secteur était et bailly coin de
petit jeune de 24 ans travaillant
finances dans c'est extrêmement
compliqué mais monter une petite plate
forme de don à une association un truc
philanthropie quoi vous attaquez pas aux
trucs très complexe assez pour les
experts et nous on était convaincu que
c'était notre inexpérience qui
permettrait de réinventer les modèles
dans le secteur financier les expertises
a été mauvaise
on a finalement on en guérit pas le
cancer quoi le but complètement de la
finance c'est que l'argent est dans
l'économie c'est pas très compliqué et
finalement on a créé une machine ultra
complexes pour servir des intérêts et
nous on a voulu casser cette machine
justement avec notre innocence
donc on a voulu travailler en finance
solidaire
et quand je dis ce terme à des gens qui
n'y connaissent pas grand chose dit me
disent nécessaire total paradoxe et même
j'irai plus loin il ya un vrai tabou en
france autour de l'argent et je vais
vous citer une petite un petit passage
qui incarne vraiment ce que les
problématiques autour du tabou de
l'argent tout attention donnée aux
choses d'argent était réputé ville et
basso suprême degrés dans ma famille il
y était en quelque sorte contre la
pudeur de parler d'argent
l'argent a été comme une triste une
nécessité et son rôle indispensable
malheureusement comme les lieux
d'aisance mais dont il ne fallait pas
parler c'est une citation de stendhal la
vie d'henri dollars donc nous on a voulu
anoblir l'argent on a voulu que l'argent
ne soit plus vue comme un outil qui
finalement scindée les classes entre
elles mais comme quelque chose qui
permettrait de revaloriser les personnes
et c'est pourquoi notre solution c'était
de créer une désintermédiation une
désintermédiation entre l'argent et
l'économie on permet en fait aux gens
avec 1000 euros 1000 euros ce n'est plus
1000 euros sur mon livret à qui fait je
sais pas trop quoi qui est juste
finalement une ligne sur mon compte
bancaire
mille euros c'est des logements sociaux
qui peuvent être créées mille euros
c'est des nouvelles énergies qui peuvent
être développées mille euros c'est une
start up qui utilise la technologie au
service du bien commun qui peut se
développer
mille euros c'est aussi peut-être la
petite boulangerie en bas de chez moi
qui emploie des personnes éloignées de
l'emploi et qu'il les emplois dans la
société et sur nos dix mille épargnant
les 10000 épargnants de l'étape en cô
tous savent exactement où va leur argent
et je pense que sur des millions
d'épargnants dans les institutions
bancaires moins de 10000 sont en
capacité de dire ça donc voilà on a donc
prouvé que ce premier stéréotypes qui
qui consiste à dire que pour réussir
évolutions sectorielles il faut être un
expert et fo maintenant on va passer au
2e stéréotypes le deuxième stéréotypes
c'est la figure qu'on a du leader
charismatique
moi personnellement j'ai toujours voulu
m'engager j'ai toujours voulu résoudre
les inégalités sociales et
environnementales
et pourtant je
n'avait pas vécu la guerre ni
d'événements historiques hors du commun
d'ailleurs j'étais issu d'une classe
plutôt aisée je n'avais pas vraiment de
problème pour étudier mais malgré tout
j'avais envie de m'engager et j'ai
grandi avec ce fantasme de l'homme sage
charismatique qui a vécu des grandes
choses qui lui donnait sa légitimité et
je me sentais complètement illégitime
face à ces grands hommes les femmes en
plus c'était très peu représenté dans ce
milieu de l'engagement non pas qu'il n'y
ait pas eu des femmes qui ont transformé
la société
mais c'est clairement pas celle-là qu'on
nous montrait à la télé mais malgré tout
j'ai décidé de m'engager avec ce bagage
émotionnel
parce que je vous assure je n'ai rien de
l'acquéreur de nelson mandela je suis
une femme hyper active à qu avec une
empathie qui approchent
l'hypersensibilité à ces passionnés
parfois un peu décousu et c est comment
est ce que je me suis engagé donc j'ai
commencé donc en classe préparatoire
rennaise cachan
j'ai fait une fac de maths dans ce noble
établissement qui m'a beaucoup appris
j'ai également après intégrer une école
de commerce le m lyon sur laquelle
j'avais énormément de préjugés non ça va
pas non plus empêché tous mes camarades
de m'appeler la rouge
mais bon en même temps qu'on a un
minimum de convictions sociales dans une
école de commerce
on est tout de suite une grosse coco et
derrière j'ai réintégré l'essec pour un
faire un master spécialisé sur la mesure
d'impact social
j'ai travaillé en inde en microfinance
sur des plateformes technologiques pour
accompagner les entrepreneurs déraisonne
rural un peu en chine et dans une grande
banque une grande institution bancaire
pour travailler sur les politiques de
désinvestissements dans le nucléaire
l'huile de palme l'armement et c est
mettre en place une révolution dans la
banque mais bon malgré tout gb ensuite
24 ans j'étais toujours inexpérimentés
et j'avais toujours pas connu la guerre
et j'ai décidé de m'engager notre milieu
de la finance éthique accepte un peu
deux postures donc la première posture
que l'on connaît vraiment l'abbé pierre
7 ce sage homme qui appelle à la
générosité du public ou la posture du
financier alors appât
beaucoup aimé louise qui j'avais pas
grand chose de la posture du financier
classique logée dans sa tour à la
défense et malgré tout j'avais envie de
travailler dans ce secteur et c'était un
peu excitant en fait finalement que de
se confronter à ce secteur là bon je
vais pas non plus vous cacher que ça n'a
pas été sans mal et que pendant les cinq
ans d'activité j'ai quand même eu le
droit à certaines remarques pour me
ramener à ma condition notamment une
fois j'étais au téléphone avec un de mes
investisseurs et devant l'insolence dont
je faisais preuve en juste exprimant ma
position de gestion sur ma propre
entreprise
il me dit eva tu va baisser un peu d'un
ton t'es gentille mais tu écoutes pas
beaucoup ah oui et là je me suis sentie
comme une petite fille qui se faisait
gronder au supermarché ou une fois un
message arié en tentant de rattraper une
de ces bourdes en rendez vous il sort et
me dit c'est quand même plus facile pour
toi développer un business
c'est à dire oui quand on est jeune
fraîche comme ça quand on salariés te
dit que la raison pour laquelle tu
réussis voilà je pense que j'irai
peut-être un petit problème dans les
sociétés ou encore ce matin je me suis
fait traiter de sale idiote par un homme
une personne que je voulais pas
accompagner et qui visiblement est un
entrepreneur très charismatique
bon c'est vrai que c'est des choses qui
arrivent quand on correspond pas à
l'archétype de son secteur et même quand
on a une boîte d'une trentaine de
personnes finalement la thèse de casser
ce deuxième stéréotypes pour moi elle
est nécessaire pourquoi parce que en
divisant l'archétype du leader né on
arrive un vrai cataclysme et pour moi je
pense qu'il faut diversifier les figures
du leadership
il faut que le leadership soit en nous
tous
sinon qu'est-ce qui se passe la
divinisation de ces personnes-là freine
le phénomène d'identification pour moi
qui est nécessaire à la propagation et
au maintien d'une vraie idéologie engagé
est également j'ai l'impression qu'à la
mort aussi de ses figures emblématiques
leurs théories engagés semblent se
perdre ou se figer avec leur mort un
petit peu
petit peu dur pour la fin de deuxième
stéréotypes mais on va passer du coup au
troisième qui pour moi est le plus
intéressant le modèle de vertus sociales
qu'on a en france on est clairement
héritier d'une culture religieuse
sociétal qui d'une certaine manière a
défini pour nous ce qui était le bien ce
qui était le mal ce qui était la vertu
ce qui était lisse qu'andre ce qui était
finalement la manière dont on devait
agir aujourd'hui et pour moi ce dernier
stéréotypes il est extrêmement
problématique
il est maintenu et conservé par les
médias que j'aime bien appeler les
prêcheurs du 21e siècle et il faut
vraiment s'en libérer parce que c'est
pas en stigmatisant et en mettant de
côté une catégorie de la population qui
pour nous ne respecte pas à ce modèle de
vertus qu'on arrivera à une vraie
transformation globale et nous on a
décidé d'avoir une posture complètement
différente
on a décidé de ne pas voir en fait de ne
pas définir ce qu'était la vertu sociale
et de travailler avec des acteurs qui
n'incarne pas du tout pour le grand
public ce progressisme sociétal donc par
exemple dans notre secteur financier qui
incarne le désastre sociétal c'est les
banques et nous on a décidé de
travailler avec les banques avec les
banques classiques parce qu'on ne les
voit pas comme des institutions
dangereuse mais on les voit comme des
groupes de personnes qui sont dans un
système très établies et plutôt que de
croire en l'institution bancaire on a
souhaité croire en les personnes qui la
composent est en fait si vous voulez pas
travailler avec les institutions
classiques qui avec les personnes que
vous considérez comme étant complètement
à l'opposé de vous on n'arrivera jamais
à transformer le système
aujourd'hui les petits actes individuels
ne permettront pas de vraiment
transformer la société
et je vais vous donner quelques
statistiques qui pour moi sont
extrêmement parlante sur la consommation
individuelle d'énergie un quart est lié
à la consommation personnelle
90% des ressources d'eau ne sont pas
utilisés par les personnes mais par
l'agriculture et l'industrie et moins de
3 % de la collecte des déchets vient des
particuliers
finalement si on veut transformer
l'économie il faut transformer le
système tel qu'il est comment finalement
nous arriverons à ce nouveau paradigme
et comment finalement opérer une vraie
transformation du système en place pour
moi je considère qu'une idée engagée est
bonne et une vraie valeur et une vraie
vertu sociale si elle arrive à passer le
filtre idéologique technique et culturel
de notre interlocuteur est pour moi la
meilleure manière de tester votre idée
engagé c'est justement de la mettre en
phase une personne qui pour vous
n'incarnez pas du tout le progressisme
sociétale je vous ai donné l'exemple des
banques je vous en donner un dernier qui
est extrêmement signifiant il ya
quelques mois on nous a vus faire une
conférence à rome et j'ai été contacté
par un proche du vatican et du cardinal
coxon disant que l'it à point qu était
un moyen magnifique d'appliquer un
projet qu'ils avaient au sein du vatican
samassa n'a éveillé s'est imposée
question en fait c'est ce qu'il me
disait c'était que le pape avait écrit
une encyclique qui s'appelait le lot
date aussi donc j'ai déjà tapé sur
google savoir ce qui était une
encyclique puis ensuite j'ai lu cette
encyclique le lot date aussi et
finalement j'ai découvert un vrai traité
d'économie durable et j'ai trouvé ça
extrêmement intéressant et du coup pour
vous la faire courte
aujourd'hui nous avons lancé avec un
projet qui a été mis en place dans le
vatican inspiré par le pape
une plateforme permettant d'accompagner
des projets qui aideront les réfugiés en
fait c'est des entrepreneurs de la
silicon valley qui ont monté au vatican
un incubateur d'entreprises qui
permettront de résoudre les
problématiques dont parle le pape dans
le lot date aussi la première
problématique a été traité était le
climat et la deuxième c'est la crise
j'aime plutôt dire la crise d'accueil
des réfugiés et donc pour pouvoir
soutenir ce projet il avait besoin d'un
produit de finances inclusif et c'est
pourquoi on a lancé il ya quelques jours
donc je vous le dis en est
cusiter la première plateforme de
financement de projets qui
accompagneront d'ici à 2020 10 millions
de réfugiés avec une approche
entrepreneuriale
donc ce n'est pas des projets
associatifs on est sur des entreprises
et le but en fait pour ces américains
nous fait toujours très dogmatique mais
travaillons ensemble c'est de créer les
gars fassent social de demain et qu'on
arrête de mettre autant de fric dans des
structures qui seront responsables
finalement deux pires externalités qui a
pu créer la et l'époque industrielle
donc voilà pour moi je considère que
pour être une vraie figure
révolutionnaire est un vrai leader de
l'engagement il le faut ni être un
expert ni un modèle de vertu ni à leader
né mais c'est qu'en s'engageant qu'on
arrivera à le devenir
merci
[Applaudissements]